This could come in handy with something like a temperature conversion. This
equation relates degree Celsius to Fahrenheit. So if I told you that the
temperature was 32 degrees in Fahrenheit, then you could quickly plug that in to
tell me that the Celsius would be, well, 0 since 32 minus 32 would equal 0. But
what if I told you the temperature was 32 degrees Celsius. Would you be able to
tell me the degrees Fahrenheit? You could plug in 32 into C and then use your
equation solving skills to figure this out but I wouldn't want to do this work
every single time for a new degree Celsius. I want an equation that just has F
solve for. So let's figure that out together. I want you to use your knowledge
of solving equations to solve for F here. Type your final answer in this box.
Remember, the equation here should contain the variables C and F. And since
you're solving for F, your equation should start with F equals. Good luck on
this one.